the kid from stranger things I saw him
in a video I was watching this the other
night he was over at headquarters which
is what you call your place with the
Metallica the kid really does was that
for real or was that a goof yes no
that's totally for real he uh
wow that was such a mind [ __ ] of a of an
experience this summer I mean who knew
you know it used to be with Metallica we
we were always the no guys hey can we
have this song for this can we have that
song for that can we have this you know
blah blah blah right and uh he was just
no no no no no no and a few years ago we
we kind of we reversed it we did a 180
and we just said you know what this is
stupid why are we hanging on to these
songs like they're so important and like
they're the crown jewels or whatever
it's like let's share a music with the
world so a couple years ago we said yes
to everything started saying yes to
everything and obviously I mean we're
all somewhat familiar with the the
strangest things phenomenon but we got
that in what six nine months ago and
said yes and they wanted to build this
whole scene around master puppets and we
said of course and then it came out over
the summer and it was just such a mind
[ __ ] to see how that became a phenomenon
and we were so proud I mean who would
have thought
40 years later that these songs could
still have that impact so we were
excited to be part of it absolutely and
it's a and it's a smart move because you
think about it in the old days you could
your music would be heard on traditional
radio it would be heard you know
whatever the hell the the way people
sold records nowadays how do you get a
younger generation to really know
Metallica and and quite frankly putting
it on Stranger Things is a brilliant
[ __ ] idea it's the it's you've got to
think differently I guess we like to
support other creative entities and
obviously if somebody's got a
a great starting independent project and
needs a favor or whatever I mean we want
to support the community in that way but
the way this strangers things took off
was just so unexpected so he came you
know he came we played together he he
knew the song he knows it was good yeah
and he was such a sweetheart and was
just so up for it and was uh
this was in what was it in July maybe he
it was just you could see that he had
spent a couple weeks in that
transformative stage where an actor
because he's uh he's not obviously like
that character at all right and English
formal trained theater actor who doesn't
look obviously or appear anything like
the character and so he comes in he's
been kind of slugging along for years
and years and years and then all of a
sudden this character gives him this
break and he was just riding the
crossbow that way where you can feel
that his life was changing and he was
talking about but going out into LA and
he was meeting with the agencies and he
was just doing all that stuff and and
what a joy to um
to share that musical moment with him
and and be part of of riding that wave
with him